nous sommes aujourd'hui une vingtaine de
randonneurs profitant des weekends
nature pour partir à la découverte des
Gorges du bas de la rivière de
Saint-Denis on part de zé en altitude
dans dans l' de la rivière environ 70 m
donc c'est très peu
pentu pour 4 km donc il y a pas de cassé
c'est très PL c'est
accessible aussi bien des des gens de de
3 4 ans 70 ans et plus accompagné de
notre guide nous longeons les berges de
la rivière contemplant ces falaises qui
nous surplombent et cette eau limpide
qui abrite de nombreux alevins c'est des
Cabau boucherond l'adulte du bichic
c'est l'adulte du bichic alors dans
cette dans cette rivée il y a deux
espèces de cabooucheron il y a leopterus
la gocéphalus il y a le cotulipus
acutupinus qui est l'endémique Réunion
Maurice dire qu'on ne trouve qu'à la
réunion à Maurice tout au long du
sentier nous profitons de ce patrimoine
paysagé exceptionnel comme ce bois de
paill en queue une plante endémique
qu'on ne retrouve qu'à la Réunion et à
l'île Maurice une espèce protégée comme
peut l'être l'habitat de ce papillon le
petit monarque le papillon orange et
blanc est
infodé à cette plante là qui s'appelle
laasclépiade de curassau qui est
justement la la plante haute la plante
qui va qui sert de support pour la
reproduction papillon petit monarque
donc si on si on enlève cette plante là
l'espèce de papillon va disparaître
automatiquement donc partout dans le
monde il existe plusieurs espèces de
d'asclépia ici on a avec la fleur orange
qu'on appelle fleur de sang mais
ailleurs on peut trouver aussi l'clépade
avec des fleurs blanches et cetera après
3 km de marche nous arrivons au barrage
d'eau de bellpierre un ouvrage datant du
18e siècle qui marque la frontière avec
le Parc national de la Réunion notre
guide en profite pour nous raconter les
technique de pêche traditionnelle dans
ces eau aujourd'hui
protégé vous savez le chocin c'est une
plante succulante donc qui qui est riche
en qui a beaucoup
de il y a qui sécrète un jus hotiant qui
irrite donc les pêcheurs le prend coupe
pile dans l'eau et donc en le jus qui
est sécrété va hriter les poissons les
poissons vont dévaller il capture les
espèces dans une nasse voilà nous
terminons notre balade par un
pique-nique à l'Î des manguier un moment
de partage et de
convivialité c'est passionnant c'est
agréable
en plus le temps de la partie et notre
guide est vraiment charmant il répond à
toutes nos questions c'est
parfait ça permet de se reconnecter un
petit peu à la nature et puis de voir
autre chose c'est qu' a des années nous
sommes ici puis c'est la première fois
queon fait la rivière le bas de la
rivière tjours pareil c'est tellement
prêt que on y va
pas